residents in gaza and israel are marking
the first day of peace after an 11-day
conflict that killed over 230 people in
gaza
and 12 in israel the ceasefire deal
brokered mostly by egypt
carries no preconditions and leaves the
conflict's key disputes
unresolved world leaders and diplomats
are now pushing for a long-term
political solution but today
residents are picking up the pieces
after the region's
worst conflict in years
the streets of gaza have come back to
life
the ceasefire has brought relief but
people here
know just how fragile peace is
life will return because this is not the
first war
and it will not be the last one normal
life will return
it is true that our hearts are in pain
there were disasters
entire families were wiped out and that
saddens us
but it is our fate in this land to be
patient
the truce was welcomed in jerusalem
where tensions flared for weeks before
fighting began it has to be done
to be honest with you because of the
bloodshed that
and the murdered and the children
that was killed that were killed and the
innocent women
everyone every soul has a value
so this has to be done but in this
israeli border town
opinions were mixed
zipped bad this is not a cease-fire
they should not have stopped what will
happen in a year
in half a year two years so
finally there is a cease-fire
both israel and hamas are claiming
victory in the conflict
the task of rebuilding now begins with
hopes
the truce will last
let's go straight to tanya krema that's
dw's
correspondent in gaza city tanya
is the ceasefire holding
well at the moment at least uh the
ceasefire seems to be holding we're in
gaza city of course that's also
on the minds of many people they're
worried about you know what could happen
if it doesn't hold so
at the moment uh it is quite in gaza but
it's a tense quiet
hamas of course portraying this as a
victory
will the ordinary people there in gaza
see it the same way
well i think it's a bit of a strange
atmosphere on the one hand of course
hamas and other militant groups portray
this as a victory but people here
now are coming out and after 11 days of
fighting of bombardment and
rocket strikes into israel and they have
to pick up their lies where they left it
11 days ago so it is not an easy
atmosphere at all
the devastation you can see it in gaza
many thousands tens of thousands of
people have
actually um lost have been displaced
so we saw some people you know slowly
going back and seeing
what is left of their home so it is not
an easy atmosphere and of course uh
there's also worry about whether the
ceasefire will hold
quite a lot for people to take in uh
how long will it be uh for gaza to
recover from all of this devastation
well it's probably hard to estimate
because the situation of gaza is not
easy it has been under a blockade for
almost
14 years that means every building
material
is it's not easy to bring it in either
from israel
or from egypt so uh we know that several
thousand
units at least have been destroyed or
severely uh damaged for people to live
in
so this will take time to rebuild of
course but i think at the moment the
focus is on
uh you know for those who have lost
loved ones you know it's a morning
period for those
who are injured to take care of them and
also for
you know the ordinary people here
somehow to pick up their lives
and that's as they say it's going to be
a difficult
uh situation for these people to resume
their lives are we seeing any
any support or anything of the scent of
the sort that will
come in if we get a sense of that
well several countries have already
pledged humanitarian aid
and there was also today because foreign
journalists like
us were led into gaza another crossing
with israel the karim shalom crossing
also
as far as we know opened for some
humanitarian aid coming in
egypt has also pledged to help there's
another crossing with egypt and the
south of gaza
so i think the international community
has also pledged to help rebuilding
but of course uh this is something
that's in the future so
um people you know for the moment
they're here and
they have to deal with what is there
here on the ground
okay dw's tanya crema in gaza city
thank you for bringing us up to speed
now israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu has hailed
the gaza offensive as an exceptional
success
and he warned hamas that there would be
a new level of force
should it resume rocket attacks on
israel now earlier today
netanyahu described what the offensive
had accomplished
we took out many targets in what they
call the metro below the gaza strip
we struck more than 100 kilometers of
that system
and we demonstrated that it was
vulnerable and could be destroyed
we eliminated more than 200 terrorists
among them 25
senior leaders including brigade
commanders
we eliminated an important part of the
hamas and islamic jihad leadership
and those who were not eliminated now
know that our long arm can reach them
anywhere
is a freelance journalist in jerusalem
and he joins us now sami welcome to the
program
are there any concerns about whether the
ceasefire will hold
yeah well i can tell you that here in
jerusalem
at the time that the palestinians have
been celebrating
what they see as a victory by the
palestinian
resistance israelis here
have had been in a different mood
but if we are just looking at the
question of whether the
ceasefire will continue or not it is
very clear that
the factions in the gaza strip are not
interested in resuming this round
and they have expressed uh just the
minutes ago again thanking the egyptians
for the role that they have
played even the events that we have seen
around the elector mosque
today uh the latest announcement has
been that
israel has withdrawn its troops from the
al-aqsa mosque so they don't see it as a
reason for a new
flare-up and what israelis have been
saying is that if there will be launches
from the gaza strip
then they will see it as a violation so
that means even if there will be a
balloon or something will be launched
from the gaza strip
there will be an israeli response so i
think one has to sometimes
look at what will happen along the
border with gaza
to see whether there will be such a
flare-up right and and what's the
situation in jerusalem looking like
right now
yeah well the situation was
after a night in which there were
thousands out in the streets
celebrating in east jerusalem and in
other
towns in the west bank there was the
friday a prayer and
i think some of the worshipers were
surprised to see
a police force in the compound of the
al-aqsa mosque
as you know the palestinian resistance
groups hamas and jihad as they refer to
themselves the palestinian resistance
they have claimed a big victory over
israel and they
talked about the fact that al-aqsa is
now has been liberated
so there was some attacks against the
policemen and the policemen responded
there were clashes
over 15 palestinians have been wounded
in these
clashes but it
seemed to be contained the situation
there has seemed to be a calm down
right um there's a report that in sheikh
there
uh israeli police are encircling the
area but
nevertheless we don't see a new round
it seems that it's calming down now
okay so nothing to threaten uh the
ceasefire at the moment
now uh a senior hamas leader ismail
haniye has been speaking
about the ceasefire can you tell us more
about what he said
so you know ismail aniye he was
thanking those who supported hamas
he was thanking iran for its
support both the military and
technological
support he was also thanking the united
nations
and egypt for their efforts to bring
about this
ceasefire and he was saying that
this has been a turning point in the
palestinian
struggle this is the narrative that that
you hear
and not only among hamas supporters but
they see this
event as being a turning point in the
sense that it has united palestinians
not only from the gaza strip but also
from the west bank
east jerusalem and even palestinians
with inside israel citizens of israel
who have been engaged during these
last few days and have expressed
solidarity
and went on strike the other day so all
of this is seen
as a victory for the resistance and
a defeat for abu mazen and mahmoud abbas
policies all right okay sami sokol in
jerusalem
thank you for bringing us up to speed